well I mean lots of Sympathy For The
Duke and Duchess of Suffolk and Mrs
Markle um I I
given what happened to
um the Duke of sussex's mother I can
only imagine how harrowing it must have
been for him and
um you know I only know that as much as
I've seen in the sort of breaking news
in the afternoon but
um I can imagine for that him and his
family it must have been
um must be very harrowing indeed I'm
sorry to hear that it happened
and the prince's taxpayerfunder protect
protection was removed when he stepped
back as a senior Royal and left the UK
to go to the United States is that the
kind of thing that maybe should be
re-looked at given what's happened
oh look I think Sophie impossible to
offer that sort of reaction on the fly
when all I've done is seen the the
breaking news I think it's appropriate
to offer my sympathies and to say how I
uh and say how awful it must have been
but without knowing any of the
circumstances impossible to comment on
behalf of the government about what the
security provision what the security
implications may be okay understood as
you say a fast moving story I will be
following lots of developments on that
of course
um the defense secretary is in Germany
and discussing continued support for
Ukraine what are the kinds of things
that we're looking at
well I mean he is in Germany to discuss
many things uh not least the uh the
future of NATO there's an important
conference coming up uh in a month or
so's time but any conversation on your
Atlantic security clearly revolves
around what's going on in Ukraine there
is a donor Community uh the UK and
Germany both very prominent within it
that are giving enormous amounts of Kit
to the ukrainians and Ben and Minister
Pistorius will have been having
discussions about what that looks like
as the offensive goes on this summer and
obviously you've seen from Ben's
comments that long-range weapons the
sort of the what the the artillery
ammunition and air defense systems and
of course fighter jets are very much the
live conversation
what is the live conversation when it
comes to fighter jets then
well the the I think the conclusion that
ukrainians have come to is that they
would very much like to operate F-16 and
there are a number of nations that
operate F-16 that have indicated a
willingness in principle to provide them
the UK doesn't operate F-16 and so what
we've said is that we will assist in the
pilot training pipeline uh to help
Pilots to learn to fly in the first
place and then of course countries that
operate F-16 will need to do the special
to type training thereafter and although
we don't have any of those Jets to
donate ourselves there are clearly
things that we can support uh the
countries that do uh donate those Jets
either through providing some Royal Air
Force capability to backfill any loss
capability on their part or to support
the uh the the maintenance and arming of
those Jets once donated
you talk there about the enormous
support that the UK has offered to
Ukraine and your new procurement
Minister said today the refresh of the
mod's defense reviews of the Defense
command paper should be released by the
end of June are there going to be cuts
to Personnel or equipment in order to
balance the books
well look the the process of looking at
the future of our Armed Forces making
sure that we have properly learned the
lessons from Ukraine uh that all of the
Innovation that we've assisted the
ukrainians in making uh to their uh you
know with their forces and that have had
such effect
um in the fight in Ukraine are quickly
absorbed into the UK Armed Forces as
well so it'd be premature in fact until
the date of publication it would
completely completely wrong to say what
those conclusions exactly are but I
suspect that your viewers whatever their
concern may be about the shape size of
the Army Navy Air Force would agree that
it is entirely incumbent on us to a make
sure that everything that we've learned
from Ukraine is reflected as quickly as
possible in our own armed forces and
that b we recognize that since we
published the last Defense command paper
the world has become ever more insecure
and ever more unstable and so we need to
make sure that we are gearing ourselves
against all of those threats and that's
exactly what we're doing uh in the work
we've got going on on the command paper
refresh at the moment
so just stripping away what you're
talking about you're not ruling out Cuts
then are you
no I mean I I'm not ruling cuts out I'm
not ruling increases out I'm saying that
it is we are on a technology Threshold
at the moment there is lots of amazing
things coming into use in all sectors of
the economy with Automation and artistic
artificial intelligence okay computing
power is improving exponentially which
means the ability to sort of crunch data
and thus to Target more effectively
means that something that might
previously have taken 10 artillery guns
and 100 rounds might in the future be
achieved by a couple of guns with 20
rounds that's the order of magnitude of
change that might be possible and what
we're doing in the mod with the
brilliant scientists that we've got in
the defense Science and Technology
Laboratories and with our brilliant
people in defense intelligence is to try
to understand all of those emerging
Technologies as much as we can see how
they've been employed in Ukraine apply
those to our Force are they part of the
things that you're looking at
um Rishi sunak is on his way to the G7
in Japan
how helpful do you think it is that his
predecessor Liz truss is at the very
same time giving a speech in Taiwan
making comments about his foreign policy
approach
well you know Liz is now a back venture
and as a parliamentarian she's entirely
in her right to speak and I think it is
you know when we're faced with the
autocratic oppression that we see from
Putin the idea that a government
Minister should try and say that this
particular Member of Parliament
shouldn't be traveling and saying what
is on her mind
um is clearly not the way we do business
in this democracy the Prime Minister
will go to the G7 and speak for the
nation Liz is in Taiwan uh reflecting
her personal View understood and there's
a couple of domestic issues that I'll be
Keen to get your view on as well um and
talk about the big changes that you've
made to the rental market today we'll be
talking to a housing campaigner um quojo
later on the program and he made quite a
good point I thought that I thought I
would steal and put to you he said local
authorities have had their funding
slashed over the last 13 years look at
the state of social housing they are now
Under Pressure to enforce this bill and
monitor landlords will they be given the
funding needed to do this what's your
answer to that well I I can't give you
the answer that the housing Minister
would give you
um I sort of
um I can give you a pretty good answer
about the impacts of quantum Computing
on the modern battle space but the exact
detail of Deluxe policy I can't what I
can say it's not a huge I'm you know
look I'm not expecting you to know every
single dotted Iron Cross T in the
housing policy but I think it is a fair
question to say look if you actually
want this to work you're going to need
local authorities to be funded properly
to do it right well before before you
come here that's exactly what I was
going to say I mean I think that
obviously when you bring in any sort of
Reform like this you want to consult
widely and make sure that it is going to
work uh this uh as I understand it is a
proposal that has indeed taken some time
to develop and so I would expect that
the point that your contributor makes is
either one that has already been
considered in the development of the
policy or is something that the
department will be Keen to engage with
to make sure that it is going to work
for local authorities in the way that He
suggests it may not okay understood
um and then just finally there is been a
lot of speculation that net migration
could hit as high as a million next week
this is legal immigration of course
important to make that distinction given
that it's legal should we be relaxed
about how high that number goes
well I think that there has been uh a
lot of effort in government to make sure
we shut down on illegal migration that
is the bit that I think the public react
to as being unfair inappropriate and
it's right that they expect their
government to control their borders as
for what our requirements are when it
comes to Legal migration I think there
are lots of economic Arguments for why
we do need Workforce to meet the needs
of certain sectors but clearly we have
to also make sure that we are not
missing the opportunity to improve our
productivity and drive Innovation into
our workplace by taking advantage of
cheap migrant labor now my senses from
what I've seen of the debate playing out
within government that that is very much
the balance that the government is
trying to strike I think it's invidious
to say that a certain number is too much
or that there should be a ceiling or
that we should be aiming for a Target
that is significantly lower we should do
what is needed for our economy whilst
recognizing that the answer to a labor
shortage isn't always more migration
actually focusing on issues of
productivity and Automation and
technology in the workplace is similarly
important